hey I just want to talk briefly about
our podcast we do have an audio podcast
of the david pakman show and lots of
people on our youtube channel will often
get in touch and say hey David you know
I like watching the clips on YouTube but
a podcast would be better for the gym or
for my work community on public transit
or whatever and the answer is yes we
have an audio podcast we've actually had
an audio podcast much longer than we've
had a YouTube channel the audio podcast
has been around it predates the YouTube
channel by several years and it's on
iTunes stitcher I Heart Radio Google
Play you can put it in any podcast app
you have the URL is feeds feedburner com
forward slash david pakman show and as
you will see if you search for david
pakman show on itunes the podcast is
available on iTunes by the way if you
have iTunes it would be really nice if
you left us a review ideally five stars
on iTunes that really actually helps in
terms of the discovery of our podcast on
iTunes if you have the stitcher mobile
app the David Pakman show is on the
stitcher mobile app notice that people
race or Pakman there yes that is an old
picture of me lecturing at I don't know
we're very very old pictures the cover
photo on on stitcher but leave us a
review or vote give us five stars on
stitcher you can also listen to the show
there we are on I Heart Radio you can
follow the David Pakman show on I Heart
Radio that podcast is also updated on a
regular basis so I get it I mean I like
I watch youtube videos when I'm you know
working on a computer sure but it's not
the best application I like a podcast
like when I go running or if I'm on
public transit or whatever I will listen
to audio podcasts and a lot of people it
would be great if more people were
listening to the audio podcast now I've
recently got more into podcasts myself
and I love just downloading them at home
yeah and then you can take it on the go
with you you don't waste your data or
anything else there you go
do you now do you have limited data
because my you do I'm guess I'm not one
of these unlimited you're not on Sprint
are you no not a sprint as far as I know
might be the only service which still
grandfather's and people on the
unlimited data plans which I still have
stunningly okay well yeah so this is
really change course into a
advertisement for Sprint no I listened I
don't get anything from them and I think
as far as coverage goes it might not
even be that good I genuinely have no
idea okay I just like unlimited data of
course it's not much use if you have no
service but this message has been
brought to you by Verizon right I have
no I am completely agnostic on which
provider will give you better service I
just know anecdotally that I do have
unlimited data and as a totally separate
note not only do we have a regular audio
podcast if you are a david pakman show
member we have a completely separate
audio podcast feed which is our full
hour show - the commercials as well as
the world-famous bonus show and you can
get that all in a Members Only podcast
feed so many audio podcast options and I
hope you will partake